sí vale
[Aplausos]
desviaron asteroides para evitar una
posible colisión con la tierra la misión
del cohete dark que tiene todos los
ingredientes de una película de
hollywood pero es real y una prueba
histórica el objetivo de la nave es
rastrear la trayectoria de un asteroide
llamado the morphos situado a 11
millones de kilómetros de la tierra
nuestra misión es chocar contra un
asteroide a 25.000 kilómetros por hora
un impacto fuerte y difícil hemos
trabajado en el diseño de una misión que
golpeara la luna de un sistema de acero
el impacto nos espera hasta dentro de 10
meses cuando los científicos tendrán la
tarea de calcular las consecuencias de
la colisión la misión se trata solo de
una prueba a escala real ya que el
asteroide es inofensivo para nuestro
planeta sin embargo la cne se está
tratando de averiguar si este tipo de
tecnología será suficiente para desviar
asteroides en el futuro en un ejercicio
de reafirmación manco o francamente de
todos los objetos cercanos a la tierra
que conocemos hoy ninguno de ellos
representa una amenaza dentro de 100
años aproximadamente
aunque la nasa dice que monitorea más de
27.000 asteroides muchos todavía se
desconocen no obstante la hipótesis de
tener que desviar uno de ellos de su
trayectoria podría hacerse realidad